okay everybody there's a lot of talk
going around right now that we could
have possibly discovered what the
post-credits scene could be for Avengers
for now having said that I have to issue
a spoiler alert in case any of this ends
up coming to fruition so if you don't
want to know about any potential
spoilers for the post-credits scene in
Avengers 4 turn back now
so everybody is talking about the
possibility of the Eternals showing up
in the post-credits scene for Avengers 4
specifically to Eternals Karen and Piper
/ sprite so who are the Eternals and why
would they put two of them in the
Avengers 4 post-credit scene well the
Eternals actually connect directly to
Thanos the Eternals were created by
space godlike beings known as the
Celestials along with their genetic
cousins the deviants as well the
Eternals have superhuman abilities
including super-strength flight
telepathy forcefield generation and
transmutation they actually mentioned
one eternal in Avengers infinity war a
Lars
that's right Thanos his father a Lars is
an eternal along with his mother soos
son as well that makes Thanos an eternal
although he carries the deviant gene
which is why he's all purple and ugly so
as you can see the Eternals connect
directly with feyo's because he is an
eternal himself his family that lived on
Titan his people they were all eternals
so why the Eternals in the post-credits
scene of Avengers 4 well Marvel Studios
has already confirmed that there's going
to be any Turtles movie and it's going
to kickstart the cosmic future of phase
4 and the MCU they've actually confirmed
all of the Eternals that are going to be
in the movie but there's been a report
by Daniel RPK at Super bro movies that
two of them will start filming before
the others he says that they started
looking to cast the roles of two of the
Eternals right now and there's a
separate breakdown out just for the two
of them what this could mean is they may
have a cameo or most likely they show up
in a post-credits scene somewhere for an
upcoming MCU film the two eternals are
Karen and Piper / sprite they will most
likely show up in a cosmic Marvel movie
so either Captain Marvel or Avengers for
a fort is more likely so basically out
of all the Eternals that are going to
appear in the Eternals movie they're
taking two of them casting them early so
they can start shooting early most
likely to put them in a post-credits
scene they're most likely to appear in
Avengers 4 and not Captain Marvel
because they're Eternals and connected
directly to Thanos and it's more likely
going to be a post-credit scene in
Avengers 4 because they don't want to
take away from the story of the Avengers
and Thanos and Avengers 4 is not only
supposed to wrap up phase 3 of the MCU
but it's supposed to wrap up the first
10 years and the Eternals is not only
one of the movies that's going to kick
off phase four of the MCU but also kick
off the cosmic future of the MCU so it
would make sense that phase 3 ends and
then in the post-credits scene they
tease phase 4 so what do you all think
about the Eternals possibly being the
post-credits scene for Avengers 4 let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and if you'd like to enter my
giveaway for your chance to win a copy
of infinity war art of the movie art
book Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 or ant-man
and the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters all
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]